[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATHAN SAWAYA: Lego has given
me the title really unique
customer, because I buy
hundreds of thousands of Lego
every month.
I used to practice corporate
law in New York City--
mergers, acquisitions,
real exciting stuff.
And I would come home after
a long day at the law firm,
and I would need
some sort of outlet.
And I would draw.
I would paint.
And sometimes I would sculpt.
It was just one day I
thought about this toy
from my childhood, Lego bricks.
Could I sculpt large scale
sculptures using this toy?
And so I started experimenting.
And I dug out all the old bricks
I had from when I was a kid
and just tried to replicate
things I saw in my apartment.
And I put together a
website which became really
my virtual gallery.
People started contacting
me and saying hey,
can you build me this?
Can you build me that?
Actually when my website
crashed from too many hits
that I realized ah,
there's something to this.
And I decided to
make that change.
And I left the law firm behind
to play with bricks full time.
The reaction from friends
and family was interesting.
And there was some people who
were a little negative about it
and thought I was crazy.
I didn't know how
long it would last.
I thought, maybe I'll be
able to pay rent next month,
but I don't know if I'll
have a job after that.
During those down times when
I didn't have something,
didn't have a
commission, that's when
I would create art for myself.
And that's really what
"The Art of the Brick"
became, this exhibition of
art that I created on my own
that now tours the globe.
The time that it takes
to create a sculpture
really depends on the size
and complexity of the piece.
So a life size human form can
take up to two to three weeks.
Something smaller could be done
maybe in a few days or a day.
The longest I've ever
worked on something
is about three months
for a sculpture
of a Tyrannosaurus rex skeleton
that was about 20 feet long.
Recently I spent two months
working on a Batmobile.
The bricks I use in my art
are the very same bricks
that people can
purchase at a toy store.
I don't paint them.
I don't have access to special
colors or special shapes
and sizes.
And we're in my art
studio today where I have
over 5 million Lego bricks.
When you look at my
sculptures up close,
you see all those sharp
corners and right angles.
And then you back away from
it, and all those corners,
they blend into curves.
And that's kind of the
magic of using Lego bricks.
You know, you don't have
to find one career path.
There are many ways to get
to where you want to go,
even if you don't know
where that is right now.
You can always
change what you are.
NARRATOR: To see how
close pro snowboarder Mike
Basich chases storms in
his mobile, tiny home,
watch this next video.
MIKE BASICH: The
view always changes,
which has been really fun.
You just pull up
the side of road,
all of a sudden you
have lakefront property,
international forest.
Next one you're on a little
creek or out in the desert.
The landscape's just amazing.
It's like having real
estate that's priceless.
Everyone misses
home at some level.
You never get
homesick with this.
NARRATOR: Thanks for watching.
Please subscribe
to "Secret Stories"
so you can see new
videos every week.